قال رئيس بلديه خان يونس علاء الدين البطه
ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي استخدمت
قنابلا شيطانيه في قصفها للمدينه واضاف ان
طواقم البلديه تعمل على حصر الاضرار
وتنظيف الدمار واعاده الخدمات الاساسيه
للمواطنين
يعني العشرين شقه افاقوا على حجم الضربه
الشديده حجما انفجار الهائل القنابل
الجديده التي لا تستخدم ضد المدنيين ولا
المواطنين ولا ضد الانسان تستخدم في مباني
فوجئنا باستخدام هذه القنابل الانشطاريه
التي انفجرت في المواطنين وتحولت اجسادهم
الاشتلاء هنا نعمل في الثلاث مسارات اول
شيء حصر الاضرار يعني وتنظيم وتنظيف يعني
بقايا الدمار حتى يعني نهيئ الحياه افضل
للسكان في المكان نمره 2 لدينا هنا شركه
الكهرباء لتقوم بايصال الكهرباء الى
البيوت حيث تم قطع الكهرباء بكامل هذه
المنظومه الان سنحاول ان نوصلها الى اكبر
عدد ممكن باستثناء الشقق التي تم تدميرها
لدينا توقم بلديه خان يونس ايضا تقوم
بالمتابعه من اجل توفير المياه اليوم باذن
الله تعالى